well I think the main thing is that the
art world is increasingly international
there are artists who are working in
centers that were previously considered
outside the art world places like
Pakistan India there their product they
might have another house in London or
they might have another studio in Paris
but they're still living in these places
and we're seeing now I mean there's a
huge boom and shine as everyone knows
there's going to be in boom in India
people imagine there's collectors
communities surging in all of these
places in Russia the Middle East China
India there's interest not only in the
art that's coming out of their own
countries but in Western art
well there there are so many biennials
now that no one can go to all of them if
you do that's your job you go to the
biennials there has been some criticism
that the biennials which are kind of
positive as this way to get the art to
interact with the city the local city
the populace of the city to me it's
questionable whether or not that happens
and how much it happens I still feel
that a lot of them are basically curated
in a way that's directed more at their
colleagues who are going to the other
biennials then to the populace of
Istanbul or Havana or wherever it is
that they're doing these shows I feel
they're speaking to each other and a lot
of occasions it's very hard to write a
review of a show that has 200 artists in
any case this is the case with Venice
this is the case with Documenta which at
least have a kind of general theme you
get to these biennials which will also
have themes you're really you have to
find a way to have a point of view
that's not just a list it's very hard
well I think what you're seeing more is
an artist trying to respond to this
global network of art fairs because the
other thing that we've seen every year
there were more art fairs every Capitol
has to have an Art Fair and there has
been a lot of commentary on how artists
are trying to produce for the fair's
which is actually a different kind of
work the work that they're going to
produce for these biennials they're
going to find some fabulous historic
location and make a site-specific work
for that location that's going to exist
in a finite period of time it might not
even be for sale because there's such
turnover at the fairs and because
there's such a large percentage of
business being done at the fairs by a
lot of galleries there are artists who
are feeling pressured to produce the
kind of work that can be shown and sold
in the fairs which occur every five
minutes
I think historically in the historically
in the last 40 years I would say that
certainly conceptual art has been much
more widely accepted in Europe than in
the United States there's certain
artists for example Joseph Kossuth who's
a very major conceptual artist who has a
much bigger career in Europe than he has
in the United States the same thing is
true with Lawrence Weiner who just had
the show at the Whitney he's huge in
Europe
I think again
everyone's watching China everyone's
watching India certainly Russia and the
Middle East in terms of the markets were
watching too